mehr als 30 jahre nach seiner ersten
bewerbung für die
präsidentschaftskandidatur charakter
stets fit gefühlt die zur wahl
gegenstand demokratie zieht joe biden
ins weiße haus ein
hier und jetzt gebe ich mein wort wenn
ihr mir das präsidentenamt anvertraut
hole ich das beste aus getroffen
er übernimmt die führung eines landes
das tief in einer corona wirtschafts und
rassismus krise steckt und er will eine
nation befrieden die wohl gespaltener
ist als je zuvor
seine große ambition ist es die
vereinigten staaten wieder zu vereinen
und das fieber auf beiden seiten wieder
runter zu kühlen
jetzt muss joe biden vor allem zeigen
wer er nicht ist
er ist nicht donald trump nach 50 jahren
in der politik nach schweren
persönlichen schicksalsschlägen ist er
nun die demokratische antwort auf einen
präsidenten der wie kaum ein anderer
polarisiert biden hatte immer mitgefühl
für andere und das ist etwas das seine
karriere definiert hat mit 78 jahren ist
joe biden der älteste präsident in der
geschichte der vereinigten staaten
kann er die trümmer aufräumen die sein
vorgänger hinterlassen hat und das land
in eine bessere zukunft führen
dritter november 2020 die nächsten tage
werden die tage des joe biden nach
langem hin und her steht fest mit
deutlichem abstand kann er sich gegen
donald trump durchsetzen
das amerikanische volk hat gesprochen
und es hat uns einen klaren sieg
beschert einen überzeugenden sieg einen
sieg für unser volk
dabei hatten viele beiden direkt zu
beginn des vorwahl marathons schon für
politisch tot erklärt als
spitzenkandidat schaffte er ist bei der
ersten vorwahl in iowa nur auf platz
vier
bei der zweiten in new hampshire sogar
nur auf platz fünf ein katastrophaler
start bei auftritten vor wählern und
während debatten mit der
innerparteilichen konkurrenz wirkte er
teilweise müde und abgekämpft
der grund für seinen schwachen start ist
dass er die letzten vier jahre keine
politik gemacht hat nachdem sein amt
endete hatte er einen ganz anderen
alltag als zuvor
und plötzlich fast vier jahre später als
kandidat wieder in den rhythmus zu
kommen
man kann das nicht einfach an- und
ausschalten
und dennoch ist er es dem die demokraten
am ehesten zutrauen donald trump zu
schlagen
die partei scheut den linksruck setzt
mit dem polit veteran beiden auf
altbewährtes und schickt mit ihm einen
mann der mitte in eine historische
wahlschlacht der jetzige präsident hat
amerika viel zu lange in dunkelheit
gehüllt zu viel wut zu viel angst zu
viel spalten beiden gibt sich als
versöhner als verstehe und so
durchschnittlich wie die amerikaner ihn
seit jahrzehnten kennen
in der ehemaligen industriestadt
scranton pennsylvania wird beiden 1942
in bescheidene familienverhältnisse
geboren
erst als die eltern nach wilmington
delaware umziehen findet der vater eine
dauerhafte arbeit
ihrem ältesten sohn joe und den
geschwistern bringen sie zusammenhalt
und durchhaltevermögen bei als beiden
seien jahrelang heftiges stottern und
den dazugehörigen sport von mitschülern
leid ist trainiert er sich den
sprachfehler mit hilfe von gedichten
selbst ab beiden ist ein fleißiger aber
durchschnittlicher student arbeitet im
sommer im schwimmbad eines vor allem von
schwarzen bewohnten viertels in
wellington er will kontakt in die black
community knüpfen
noch vor seinem juraabschluss heiratet
beiden seine große liebe lilia hunter
den jungen familienvater zieht es in die
politik
er ist erst 29 jahre alt als er für den
us senat in washington kandidiert und
gewinnt das war ein typ der präsident
werden wollte sobald er in den us senat
kam überambitioniert für jemanden mit
seiner herkunft aber er war durstig
danach doch bevor der neue junge star
der demokraten tatsächlich nach
washington um zieht der erste schwere
schicksalsschlag lilia beiden und die
gemeinsame tochter sterben bei einem
autounfall
die beiden söhne werden verletzt beiden
überlegt seine politische karriere zu
beenden und schwört dann im krankenhaus
doch den eid auf die verfassung da war
dieser junge mann den die leute nicht
kann er war vorher noch nicht einmal in
der landespolitik aber durch diesen
ersten schicksalsschlag in seinem leben
hat er die aufmerksamkeit der ganzen
nation bekommen
er hatte immer mitgefühl für andere und
das ist etwas das seiner karriere
definiert als beiden vizepräsident ist
wird bei seinem ältesten sohn beau ein
bösartiger gehirntumor diagnostiziert
2015 stirbt auch er
beides biografie ist eine öffentliche
leidensgeschichte die er in seiner
wahlkampf kampagne für sich genutzt hat
ich höre euch zu fühlen mit euch ist
seine botschaft als krasser gegenpol zu
den jobs klein wie geht's dir wenn sie
präsident werden sorgen sie bitte dafür
dass wir gute landesweite und lokale
gesetze bekommen vor allem wenn es um
polizeigewalt geht wenn tram poltert
gibt sich beiden seriös und präsidial
wenn trump seine anhänger an peitscht
richtung kapitol zu laufen um die
angeblich gestohlene wahl zurück zu
erobern und jena an zu finden die es
wagen anders zu denken umarmt joe biden
einen seiner größten gegner der
vergangenheit
wenn mike band bei der inauguration
dabei sein möchte wäre es mir eine ehre
ihn zu entfernen wenn zeugen den
medienberichten wie trump gefallene
soldaten als verlierer und trottel
bezeichnet und der präsident selbst auf
tonbandaufnahmen zugibt die gefahr des
corinna virus öffentlicher ämter
gespielt zu haben
tritt beiden auf als das moralische
gewissen des landes
mein sohn ist als freiwilliger mit der
us-armee in den irak gegangen
er war kein trottel die mit denen er
gedient hat vor allem die die nicht
zurückkamen waren keine verlierer
trump wusste um die gefahr
und als die tödliche krankheit in
relation zerriss hat er seinen job mit
absicht gemacht
wer zum henker denkt der wehr ist joe
biden der anti trump
mit einer kampagne die er zu beginn der
krise über monate hinweg nur aus seinem
privat keller führte der moderate
demokrat erklärt langeweile zum
wahlkampf prinzip ruhige wohldosierte
auftritte wenige aussagen bleiben hängen
es geht vor allem um die eine botschaft
ich bin nicht donald j es kommt selten
vor dass ein amtierender präsident aus
dem amt geworfen wird
passiert ist es schon aber eben nur
wenige male doch jedes mal wenn es dazu
kam war die presse gewandt auf eine ganz
besondere art und weise das genaue
gegenteil des vorherigen amtsinhabers
die korona krise erlaubt joe biden einen
wahlkampf auf sprache
die meisten auftritte per livestream
wenn er unterwegs ist wird nur ein
kleiner presse zugelassen
antworten auf spontane fragen gibt es
selten so kann beiden auch eine seiner
größten schwächen verstecken seine
patzer und versprecher in spontanen
situationen
wir stellen die wahrheit über fahrten
arme kinder sind so schlau und
talentiert die weiße kinder männer und
frauen sind dings der tramp kampagne
liefert der demokrat dadurch jede menge
munition beinah mantraartig versucht sie
in wahlkampfspots beiden zu unterstellen
nicht mehr ganz auf der höhe zu sein
lasst uns die schlafmützen der sagt
immer die namen falsch
ich sehe ihn nicht als gefahr er ist
eher eine gefahr für sich selbst werde
in einer debatte nicht schlägt der hat
ein ernsthaftes problem
trump hatte so versucht zu übertönen das
ihm mit joe biden ein erfahrener
vollblutpolitiker gegenübersteht
einer der in seinen 36 jahren als us
senator unzählige kompromisse mit den
republikanern geschlossen hat der als
ein guter vermittler gilt mit
verbündeten in beiden lagern als
vizepräsident unter barack obama etwa
verhandelte er die gesundheitsreform
obamacare maßgeblich mit zum ende seiner
amtszeit gibt es vom chef mit der
freiheitsmedaille die höchste zivile
auszeichnung der usa
aber in seiner langen politkarriere
steht beiden auch nicht immer auf der
richtigen seite der geschichte
als die abwehr amerikanerin liter hill
1991 dem kandidatin für den obersten
gerichtshof sexuelle belästigung
vorwirft sorgt beiden als vorsitzender
des justizausschusses nicht für eine
faire anhörung 1994 schreibt er an der
kreml mit ein gesetz das schon minder
schwere straftaten handelt und vor allem
junge schwarze männer hinter gitter
bringt 2002 stimmt er für den irakkrieg
der zum außenpolitischen desaster wird
in den vorwahlen hat beiden eine menge
contra von den eigenen leuten bekommen
und das lag auch an der kreml die joe
biden als vorsitzender des
justizausschusses durch den senat
gebracht hat
damit haben wir die polizei
militarisiert und es stellt sich heraus
das war keine harte idee die
inhaftierung rate von afro amerikanern
und anderen menschen auf color in
unseren gefängnissen ist massiv
gestiegen
dieses gesetz ist zum großen teil dafür
verantwortlich
jetzt möchte joe biden der heiler für
ein land sein das zuletzt einen
beispiellosen ausbruch der gewalt
gesehen hat er will die tief gespaltene
gesellschaft wieder vereinen und
zunächst damit beginnen die vorfälle am
kapitalintensiv aufzuarbeiten
wir müssen genauestens untersuchen wie
das sicherheitskonzept so versagen
konnte ich möchte keine voreiligen
schlüsse ziehen aber es ist doch
unglaublich dass die leute einfach die
treppen hoch laufen und in das gebäude
stören konnten
was war da passiert dem müssen wir auf
den grund gehen und die verantwortlichen
ausfindig machen dass so etwas nie
wieder passieren kann
außerdem verspricht beiden ein besseres
management der korona krise um vor allem
menschenleben zu retten aber auch um die
am boden liegende wirtschaft wieder
anzukurbeln
mit einem weiteren millionenschweren
hilfsprogramm gegenfinanzieren sollen
das unter anderem steuererhöhungen für
vermögende und unternehmen maßnahmen die
das gegenteil der politik seines
vorgängers
worum es beiden in den ersten 100 tagen
im kern geht ist also schnell
zusammengefasst
ich will dass wir uns in den griff
bekommen christoph haben und wieder
wirtschaftswachstum sehen dass
überwiegend demokratischer
abgeordnetenhaus und die
gestaltungsmehrheit im senat machen es
für beiden viel einfacher die nation
durch diese schwierige situation durch
wenn der senat in republikanischer hand
geblieben wäre mit mitch mcconnell an
der spitze wenn das so gekommen wäre
hätte joe biden seiner agenda dramatisch
anpassen müssen um sie durch den
kongress zu bekommen
dabei setzt er auf ein kabinett das die
diversität des landes widerspiegeln soll
mit genauso vielen frauen wie männern
zum beispiel ein novum auch dass
angehörige von minderheiten die mehrheit
stellen
so ist es das erste mal dass ein
bekennender homosexueller und eine
amerikanische ureinwohnerin minister
posten bekleiden werden zum ersten mal
eine frau finanzministerien und ein
schwarzer verteidigungs muster wird ihm
war natürlich klar dass man gerade jetzt
leute braucht über deren qualifikation
man nicht lange streiten lässt die
erfahren sind und schon vorher wichtige
hohe ämter innehatten
dieses kabinett muss sofort loslegen mit
der arbeit um amerikas probleme
anzugehen und es gemeinsam mit dem
präsidenten wieder auf die beine zu
bringen
unterm strich könnte man sagen beiden
großes ziel ist es erstmal den status
quo der fortschritt zeit wieder
herzustellen
eine rückkehr zur normalität sozusagen
im moment scheint es so als sei das die
größte herausforderung vor der angehende
us-präsidenten in moderner zeit standen